Hi, I'm Dave from the Burp Scanner development team and today I'm going to talk a little bit
about how you can extend the power of Burp Scanner through B-Checks. Burp Scanner comes
prepackaged with a wide range of scan checks targeting common vulnerability classes like
SQL injection and XSS but tends to avoid technology specific issues. An example of this would be the
log4shell vulnerability that appeared in late 2021. In order to enable Burp Scanner to find
these vulnerabilities you either had to hope that an extension already existed to find it or you had
to write an extension yourself. In Burp Suite Professional 2023.6 we added B-Checks to help reduce
the time required to write custom scan checks and plug them directly into Burp Scanner. So let's head
on over to Burp Suite to see how it works. In Burp Suite 2023.6 under the extensions tab there is a
new tab called B-Checks. From here you can either write your own check or you can import a check that's
been created by another member of the Burp Suite community. We have a list of checks that's
available on a github page and the link for that will be available in the description of this video.
When creating your own check we have a series of templates to help get you started and these cover
host level checks, insertion point level checks and even out of band or OS level checks that use
Burp Collaborator. For this video I'm going to target a vulnerability on Portswickers Gin and Juice
which is a deliberately vulnerable web application used to evaluate scanners. On the vulnerabilities
page of Gin and Juice we can see that the catalog page has a SQL injection vulnerability and if we
head over to the catalog page and click on one of the categories we can see that we've got a query
parameter to work with. So let's write a check that's going to try and find SQL injection for
this query parameter. So back in the B-Checks tab I'm going to start by creating a new B-Check.
The first thing that I'm going to do is I'm going to create my metadata block. The metadata block just
includes the name of the check which is also the name of the vulnerability if it finds one,
a description of what the check does and the author tag so that you can take credit for all
of your checks later. The first thing I'm going to do in this B-Check is I'm going to check the status
code of the base response to make sure that we didn't get a server error for the base response. If
that's all good I'm going to send a payload which will append a single quote to the base value for
the insertion point. I'm also going to name this payload so that I can refer to it later. If the
payload causes the application to change the status code then we're going to send a follow-up request
that is going to append two single quotes to the base value of the insertion point. If that then causes
the application to revert to the original status code then we've found an issue. If the status code
is back to the original one then we can report the issue and we can add lots of detail and remediation
information. Now that we've created our check let's go and test it out. This is the request that I
identified before from Gin and G-Shop that includes our SQL injection vulnerability. If I am to run a scan of
this with our new audit checked only configuration we can see that a SQL injection vulnerability has
been reported and we can see the requests and responses that were sent by the scanner and received
and all of the evidence and highlights that prove that an issue was was present. We can even see what
the status code changed to when we sent payload. So we're actively working on ways to improve the workflow
of creating and testing B-Checks so watch this space for updates. For the time being give B-Checks a go
and feel free to head over to our B-Checks Git repository and raise feature requests or pull requests there.
So we're going to get to the right now.
So we're going to get to the right now. So we're going to get to the right now. So we're going to get to the right
now. So we're going to get to the right now. So we're going to get to the right now. So we're going to get to the right